der revolutionär mit bad feiert
geburtstag
vor 200 jahren wurde karl marx geboren
und alles fragt taugen marx ideen heute
noch um unsere gesellschaftsverhältnisse
zu analysieren
eine die sich darüber seit vielen jahren
gedanken macht ist rahel jaeggi
sie ist professorin für praktische
philosophie an der humboldt universität
zu berlin und hat vor kurzem zwei
millionen euro erhalten für ein neues
forschungszentrum um sich genau diesen
fragen zu widmen
herzlich willkommen projekt in guten 2
millionen euro um die krise von
kapitalismus und demokratie zu
erforschen so was passiert dann
wahrscheinlich nicht alle tage
nein das passiert nicht alle tage das
ist tatsächlich ein sehr glücklicher
umstand auch eine sehr glückliche fügung
gewesen und eben tatsächlich etwas was
einem gewissermaßen in den schoß
gefallen ist oder mehr in den schoß
gefallen ist wo man normalerweise doch
ein sehr viel längeren vorlauf hat und
sich auch bewerben muss so zusagen für
gelder jetzt hat ja dieser hamburger
unternehmer erck rickmers dieses geld so
zusammen gespendet und vier
unterschiedliche forschungsinstitut in
santa barbara in cambridge venedig und
eben in berlin an ihrer universität und
er selber wurde reich mit einem globalen
handel mit containerschiffen
da fragt man sich natürlich kann man
jetzt reich werden im kapitalismus und
nachher das geld spenden haben ist
erforschen
na ja das ist eine gute frage ganz ganz
ungewöhnlich ist das ja nicht muss man
sagen gerade wenn sie auf wenn wir hier
über marx reden
engels der ja bekanntlich
unternehmersohn war war ich ja nun einer
derjenigen die maßgeblich
mitverantwortlich dafür war dass marx
sein werk überhaupt schreiben konnte der
ja durch dick und dünn und sehr karge
zeiten gegangen ist und immer wieder
finanziell abhängig war immer wieder
finanziell gefördert worden ist von
seinem mitarbeiter die kritische theorie
im grunde wäre auch ohne die spende
eines unternehmers
das ist ja
zustande gekommen das frankfurter
institut für sozialforschung
auf initiative von felix weil der
wiederum das mit mitteln seines
ebenfalls unternehmer vaters hat
finanzieren können also ganz
ungewöhnlich ist es nicht aber natürlich
kann man sagen das ist hat schon eine
gewisse ponte kapitalismuskritik mit den
aus eben solchen unternehmen
erwirtschafteten geld es zeigt aber ja
vielleicht auch dass die besorgnis
darüber was in der welt passiert und die
besorgnis über die krisen des
kapitalismus das was der kapitalismus an
lebensverhältnissen produziert doch sehr
weit
auch in die kreise derer die eigentlich
davon profitieren hin eingedrungen ist
sie haben sich für ein pressebild was
ich gefunden habe als ich recherchiert
habe mit dem krieg muss diesen
unternehmer in der halle der humboldt
universität zu berlin fotografieren
lassen da posieren sie vor dem ganz
berühmten feuer vor der feuerbach these
von karl marx das stets in die wand
gemeistert in der eingangshalle der
haben steht es die philosophen haben die
welt immer nur interpretiert es kommt
aber darauf an sie zu verändern
ist das auch ihr persönlicher anspruch
als philosophin die welt zu verändern
mit philosophie
allerdings sollte man da glaube ich die
philosophie weder über- noch
unterstützen natürlich ist es so dass
philosophie in der und durch die analyse
in der und durch die kritik
gesellschaftlicher verhältnisse etwas in
bewegung setzen kann oder als eine art
katalysator wirken kann
der zum beispiel auf das
selbstverständnis soziale akteure
sozialer bewegungen einwirkt also
philosophie kann da viel tun entweder
indem sie dinge den geklärt dinge
zusammenhänge darlegt begriffe denken
sie an begriffe wie ausbeutung
entfremdung analysen von
herrschaftsverhältnissen auch da wo sie
nicht ganz offen zu tage legen sondern
eher in den tieferen struktur in einer
gesellschaft verankert sind und da sind
wir ja schon mitten bei marx eigentlich
das sind natürlich dinge die die
philosophie tut und damit bewirkt sie
etwas dass das unmittelbar der
weltverbesserung im sinne der
finden es von rezepten zur
weltverbesserung und veränderung dient
das kann man natürlich nicht erwarten
dazu braucht das ganz andere kräfte dazu
braucht es bedingungen unter denen man
soziale verhältnisse verändern kann dazu
braucht es akteure die bereits in das zu
tun dazu braucht das bestimmte
politische konstellation also
philosophie wird nicht unmittelbar
direkt zur veränderung beitragen aber
sie wird ist sie kann es wenn sie als
philosophie welt halt ich ist und
interessiert ist daran die verhältnisse
zu verstehen und sie zu bewerten und sie
durch das verstehen bewerten zu können
kann sie eine wirkung entfalten und wie
das alles zusammenhängt sozusagen das
denken das arbeiten und begriffen und
wirklich die konkrete veränderung der
welt darüber werden die auch sprechen
das ist auch eines ihrer großen themen
wie denken wir fortschritt
beispielsweise mit marx und wie gelingt
die veränderung der welt es ist ja jetzt
marx ja wir haben es schon gesagt 200
jahre ist der geburtstag her und es geht
vergeht kaum ein tag und ich neues buch
auf unserer redaktion landet ich habe
nur gerade mal vier mitgenommen von
einem hohen stapel neuer marx
publikationen gibt es denn noch was
neues zu marx zu sagen möchten sich auch
gerne noch ein weiteres magst und oral
pflegen
also ich selber lege kein neues max
bucht darauf allerdings muss ich sagen
das ist das eine sagen wir mal mehr mal
weniger offensichtliche rolle für meine
überlegungen spielt und für vieles was
ich in der philosophie tour gibt es dann
noch etwas neues ja ich glaube schon
also ich hab ich glaube es gibt
verschiedene tendenzen die die sehr
interessant sind jetzt gibt tendenzen
die also jetzt auch in der neueren
literatur nicht nur gibt es natürlich
philologisch neue erkenntnisse also es
gibt nicht arbeiten dann wirklich
arbeiten anschrift und wo man dann wenn
man bestimmte dinge in einem
einen anderen kontext auch werk in der
berg entwicklung sieht oder wenn man
sozusagen fragmente die ursprünglich mal
nicht zu einem bestimmten kurs dazu
gerechnet worden sei da auf einmal dann
doch in zusammenhang sie ergeben sich
immer wieder so ist solche philologische
und hermeneutische arbeit ergeben sich
immer wieder neue perspektiven das ist
das eine
das zweite ist was ich im moment sehr
interessant finde sind versuche marx
stärker zu kontextualisierung also
zusehen dass er eben in einer bestimmten
zeit in der politischen konstellation
einer bestimmten zeit geschrieben hat
sehr interessant finde ich
beispielsweise überlegungen die in viel
stärker ist das vorher so oder also in
manchen hinsichten der fall war
in wirklich auch in den kontext der
damaligen sozialistischen bewegung und
der verschiedenen formen der
kapitalismuskritik die eben schon dabei
als max kam zu setzen es gibt jemand hat
gesagt man müsse sich klarmachen dass
max im grunde ein newcomer in dieser
szene war da gab es schon große figuren
der sehr bedeutend werden und max hat
dort in diese also sozusagen im kontext
der sowohl auslegung dessen was
kapitalismus ist worunter wir leiden und
warum wir ihn bekämpfen und es übel
aufpassen sollten hat er sowohl eine
neue analyse ist auch die den versuch
bestimmte positionen die es schon gab zu
kritisieren und das sozusagen
detaillierte herauszufinden wie
bestimmte stimmt im moment das mag schon
wirklich auch direkt als intervention
verstanden werden können das finde ich
jetzt persönlich eine serie also einfach
eine interessante neue entwicklung weil
einem das so das gespür auch für die
damalige politische relevanz des werks
gibt und gleichzeitig das hervorbringt
was glaube ich wichtig ist zu sehen man
denkt ja so nachdem viele jahre über mag
es gar nicht so viel geredet worden ist
jedenfalls nicht also nicht in der
philosophie wirklich sagen oder viel
weniger
man hat im nachhinein immer wird immer
dass man sieht es in gewisser weise ja
von den siegern her davon her dass wenn
man etwas liest dann liest man mag's und
nicht die debatten die es damals gab und
man sieht ihnen deshalb man kommt gar
nicht auf die idee dass er
im grunde sich durchsetzen musste gegen
sehr viel regierte positionen schon es
ist natürlich immer so oder das so
einzelne denke an diesem inseln immer
sichtbar bleiben und es gibt ganz viele
die dieses denken auch vorbereitet und
geprägt haben
bevor wir vielleicht einzelne ideen von
marx uns ein bisschen genauer angucken
möchte ich tatsächlich ein schritt
zurück machen und mal kurz mit ihnen
auch ein paar bilder anschauen
zur theorie von marx eine zentrale frage
die max umtrieb und bilden der noch
heute kämpfe ausgefochten werden was ist
der wert einer ware
seine antwort es kommt auf die dafür
aufgewendete arbeit an arbeiter
verkaufen ihre arbeitskraft und stellen
dafür waren her
diese sind so viel wert wie die arbeit
die es für ihre herstellung braucht die
arbeit wiederum ist so viel wert wie der
arbeiter zum überleben braucht arbeitete
er mehr wozu ihnen die kapitalisten
zwingen entsteht mehr wert
[Musik]
dieser mehrwert kommt voll und ganz den
kapitalisten zugute das heißt die
kapitalisten bereichen sich auf kosten
der arbeiterklasse
laut marx kann das auf die dauer nicht
gut gehen denn der technische
fortschritt führt dazu dass es immer
weniger arbeiter braucht um waren
herzustellen
viele werden arbeitslos die arbeiter
haben zu wenig geld um waren zu kaufen
der kapitalismus führt so seinen
zusammenbruch selber herbei
womit marx nicht rechnete war der
aufstieg der gewerkschaften
diese setzten ihre forderungen gegen die
kapitalisten durch und die
industrialisierung bescherte großen
teilen der bevölkerung materiellen
wohlstand
marx selber erlag übrigens den
verlockungen des kapitalismus
er spekulierte mit us-anleihen und
englischen aktienmarkt hatte diese idee
dass der kapitalismus sich eigentlich
selber abschafft er sagt auch der
kapitalismus produziere seine eigenen
totengräber aber es wurde jetzt gerade
schon gesagt wir sehen auch dass
weltweit gesehen die armut ja extrem
abnimmt hat er sich da nicht einfach
geehrt dass mit den totengräbern muss
man glaube ich schon so verstehen er
schafft sich seine eigenen totengräber
weil er sich die bedingungen schafft
dafür oder weil er die bedingungen dafür
schafft sich selber abzuschaffen und
zwar sowohl im positiven sinne nämlich
tatsächlich die möglichkeiten die
potenziale den gesellschaftlichen
reichtum das wissen all das was dazu
gehört aber auch im negativen sinne
die möglichkeiten im sinne von einer
tiefen krise in die der kapitalismus
geraten könnte aber diese totengräber
müssen dann auch graben und das war
glaube ich nicht so also man liest mag
es gerne so als ob er geglaubt hätte der
kapitalismus schafft sich in dem sinne
von selber aggressiv geht so von selber
vorbei da muss gerade niemand mehr etwas
tun weil das die objektiven bedingungen
die hier die das dann schon von selber
erledigen werden als sei das ein natur
prozessor hat auch marx das nicht
gesehen und sich bemühen und musikanlage
und ein bisschen 'schon auch tragen
schon auch graben die totengräber müssen
sich auch zusammen finden wenn wir in
dem bett bleiben wollen wir müssen also
das bewusstsein ihrer kollektiven
situation und zu sagen die politische
handlungsfähigkeit auch erst einmal
erwerben
es gibt ein schönes zitat in dem er sagt
wenn ihr das nicht selber macht dann
werdet ihr ganz elend also an die
arbeiterklasse gerichtet dann werdet ihr
ganz elend auf den hund kommen also da
würde ich es nicht einfach so ja der
kapitalismus macht das alles selber und
die sozialen akteure sind ja eigentlich
ein rädchen die ohne wissen und wollen
aber bleiben wir in diesem punkt noch
ein bisschen dran dann ich glaube es ist
wichtig einfach um die these auch noch
besser zu verstehen wenn wir die
globalisierung betrachten die
industrialisierung betrachten dann noch
einmal sieht man ja doch das für viele
menschen auch wenn wir sagen würden die
arbeitsbedingungen sind vielleicht
grauenhaft in gewissen ländern dieser
welt hat es für sie einen fortschritt
bedeutet mit blick auf wohlstand
wie gehen sie damit um
also kann man da nicht irgendwie auch
sagen da es sich wirklich kapitalismus
kann auch zum guten der menschen seien
also dass ich bin die letzte die sagen
würde man muss an allem festhalten das
was man jetzt gesagt und da kann sich
dann nicht geirrt haben das wäre ja für
eine theorie die derart daran
interessiert ist die bedingungen also
historischen bedingungen und auch sehr
spezifische konstellation zu analysieren
wäre das ja ganz witzig kapitalismus hat
hat sich natürlich verändert in ganz
viele richtung die vielleicht nicht
voraussehbar war voraussehbar waren und
bedingungen verändern sich insofern ich
und ich glaube dass die sagen wir sehr
einfach aufgefasste vorstellung davon
das gerät alles in eine tiefe krise und
geht daran zugrunde beziehungsweise
kriegt dann sozusagen den den aufwand
zum besseren
dass die ohnehin sehr sehr problematisch
ist der kapitalismus gerät nicht einfach
so in eine krise diese krisen sind sind
krisen derart dass weil es um soziale
verhältnisse um gesellschaften um
menschen gibt sinn sind das krisen die
immer auch eine normative dimension
haben das ist nicht einfach nur so dass
der kapitalismus irgendwie nicht mehr
funktioniert und die menschen nicht mehr
nicht mehr ernähren kann damit haben
innovative dimensionen dass es auch
darum geht dass die art und weise wie es
funktioniert falsch ist und dass
menschen so nicht leben wollen wie sie
unter diesen bedingungen leben
also das ist ja wahrscheinlich ein
wichtiger moment auch haben diese
unterscheidung gemacht es gibt
einerseits rein jetzt vielleicht
materiell zwar mehr wohlstand oder
wachstum aber die frage ist doch wie
fühlen sich die menschen eigentlich
dabei bevor wir das vielleicht vertiefen
würde ich gerne auch noch einen punkt
aufnehmen weil sie das glaube ich das
ganz ganz wichtiger punkt ist der
kapitalismus den marx kritisiert hat den
gibt es ja heute so gar nicht mehr wir
haben heute so polit ökonomische
mischformen mit kapitalistischen
elementen aber auch mit sozialistischen
elementen oder sie würden auch sagen das
ist ein anderer kapitale heute
kapitalismus kritisieren kritisieren wir
wahrscheinlich etwas anderes gibt es
leider so sagen wir ja aber genau das
hatte marx im blick und dass ich noch
genau gleich
also zunächst einmal würde ich also doch
gerne noch ein satz zu der frage ist
denn die die analyse das ist für große
einen großen teil der menschen ein
großes elend bedeutet ist sie noch
richtig oder nicht und da jetzt gesagt
es hat sich gezeigt dass es das ist doch
ein eher eine allgemeine
aufwärtsentwicklung gibt das kann man
natürlich mit vielen gründen kritisieren
man könnte sagen oder in frage stellen
wenn man die sich die globale
entwicklung anguckt kann man ja ebenso
gut sagen da ist doch vieles also im
grunde ist die these dass wir eine immer
größere ungleichverteilung der
gesellschaftlichen ressourcen haben und
dass wir eine entwicklung haben die in
ganz vielen hinsichten
nicht nachhaltig ist also nicht
nachhaltig im sinne von da gibt es
wirklich moment wo man denkt hier kann
ein system seine eigenen bestands
voraussetzung nicht reproduzieren das
also da gibt es gewissermaßen
entwicklungen ökologische entwicklung
sozialer entwicklung entwicklung ganz
verschiedener art wo man glaube ich mit
gutem recht eigentlich wieder aus seiner
krisen diagnose zurückkommt und sagen
kann und sagen muss das ist eine in
verlesen doch sehen des funktionales und
des integratives system das fand ich
auch sagen aber auch schere ist ja liegt
ja auf der hand es kann man sagen na ja
vielleicht ist insgesamt der kalorien
die kalorien versorgung weltweit
betrachtet um durchschnittlich hoch
gegangen aber man weiß ja auch wie stark
die wie krass die differenzen worden
sind und dass das im moment gar kein
ende zu nehmen scheint und das hat eine
extreme armut nimmt ab aber ungleich
nimmt zu und gleich nimmt zu und nimmt
auch in unseren ländern also in denen
eigentlich bevorzugten ländern der
westlichen welt und gehört zu der abbau
an
auch sozialstaatlichen ressourcen
wohlfahrtsstaatlichen elementen die
tatsächlich eine bestimmte phase des
nachkriegs kapitalismus ausgemacht haben
ist ja auch liegt auch auf der hand dass
wir da gerade wieder eine ganz andere
bewegung erfahren haben also so einfach
glaube ich kann man kann man die these
da hat er sich geirrt gar nicht
unterschreiben dann muss das verständnis
starb sehen ja es stehe ich sehr gut und
vielleicht könnten wir ja auch ein
element aufnehmen wo im moment sehr oft
gesagt jetzt genau da ist marx
hochaktuell nämlich der prozess der
digitalisierung
da gibt es viele die das im moment
betonen ich habe einen artikel gelesen
von min li marti und balthasar glättli
der schweiz sehr gut kein nationalräte
die gemeinsam ein papier verfasst haben
für einen band von beate trinker und
cédric wermuth der heißt max neu marx
der kommt erst noch raus und da beziehen
sie sich auf das sogenannte maschinen
fragmenten und sie sagen im grunde
genommen ist ein text von marx und sie
sagen dass ich eigentlich interessant
dass marx schon ganz früh eigentlich
darauf hingewiesen hat oder man kann die
digitalisierung sofa stehen
das genau da er richtig wird immer mehr
muss produziert werden also setzten die
immer mehr maschinen ein das führt dazu
dass es immer weniger jobs gibt und
schlussendlich haben die eigentliche
plötzlich ein kollaps des systems aber
in maschinen fragment sagt marx eben
auch die maschinerie also wenn alles von
maschinen produziert wird die könnte uns
auch befreien und diese doppelt gibt es
ja moment gerade mit blick auf die
digitalisierung wie sehen sie das
also ich glaube auch dass ich glaube
nicht dass man immer alles auch schon
aus marcs rausholen muss also natürlich
kann man immer je nachdem wie man
autoren auf was sind und interpretiert
findet man viele probleme die später
entstanden sind darin schon angelegt und
ich glaube da gibt es viel mehr als man
denkt also bei max auch zu holen das
gilt auch für ganz andere fragen wenn
heutzutage aus dass vom standpunkt der
postkolonialen theorie her gesucht wird
es gibt es nicht denn wenn sozusagen
also es gibt ja dass das problem am
marxismus dass sie sehr stark aus sicht
genau eines entwicklungs typs nämlich
das entwicklungs typs gewissermaßen der
westlichen welt mit der westlichen
moderne
wo industrialisierung in england im
grunde immer der prototyp dessen wie die
entwicklung passiert waren man fragt
sich dann das was ist eigentlich mit all
den anderen ländern in denen
entwicklungsschritte und dynamiken ganz
anderer art passiert sind und das ist
einer der also gute gründe dafür auch in
kritischen blick auf marx zu werfen
diese art von sozusagen exzentrischer
perspektive wenn man wenn man sozusagen
informiert durch die politischen
bewegungen und die politische
konstellation die so etwas aufgreift
sich auf max nochmal zurück findet wird
man aber finden dass gerade auch der
späte mag sich sehr wohl und sehr viel
gedanken darüber gemacht hat dass es
sehr unterschiedliche
entwicklungsdynamik geben kann das
sozusagen die die zentrierung von diesem
rein von von dem blick denn nur auf
diesen einen dieses einem modell
gerichtet war durchaus auch da schon zu
finden ist das ist vielleicht zusammen
auch mit der frage gibt es bei marx auch
schon etwas für die ökologische frage zu
finden gibt es bei max auch schon etwas
zu finden
hinsichtlich der
geschlechter ungleichheit man kann immer
also ich glaube das funktioniert mal so
es gibt bewegung dieser etwas
thematisieren und dann kann man sich
geschäft kritisch geschäft mit einem
solchen blick auch auf das magische weg
zurückfinden und wird finden man kann da
etwas daraus machen meinte man muss es
vielleicht nicht wer tatsächlich kommen
diese probleme in anderen kontexten auf
aber es ist interessant zu sehen dass es
eben auch doch schon sehr viel
jan vorhersage gab oder an der sozusagen
das in der marktanalyse auch elemente
gibt die wirklich sehr sehr
vorausschauend waren das geht ganz
sicher für die globalisierung also max
hat den kapitalismus ja von anfang an im
grunde ist ein globales unternehmen
verstanden oder als eines das
letztendlich nur global sein können wird
und das geht glaube ich für die
digitalisierung auch also ich meine
diese tendenzen zu sagen die maschinerie
die zunehmend die notwendigkeit auch
noch lebendiger adventskränze setzen
überflüssig machen wird und die
dynamiken die sich daraus entwickeln das
ist ganz sicher auch etwas was wo sie
was für mag es jetzt nicht so
überraschend ist sicherlich hat er nicht
genau diese technologie ja gesehen ich
glaube mich wieder auch noch
interessieren auch wenn das jetzt über
marx exegese ihnen umgeht wie bewerten
dir denn diese prozessen wie tun sie das
die ja sie haben am anfang die kritische
theorie erwähnt und tatsächlich befassen
die sich in ihrer forschung immer wieder
mit marx aber eben auch schwerpunktmäßig
mit kritischer theorie also der
frankfurter schule horkheimer adorno die
ja immer die gesellschaftsverhältnis
eben den blick nimmt
und wenn jetzt noch einmal dieses thema
auf neben arbeit und digitalisierung die
einen sehen das als drohkulisse ganz
viele jobs werden verschwinden dass wir
die schere noch mehr aufmachen und
andere sehen das heißt ein
befreiungsschlag und minister ein dass
er in den blick gekommen das habe ich im
fundus bei uns gefunden das gibt es aber
auch an der zhdk zürcher hochschule der
künste hat das auch in der sammlung mit
marc sahr weniger arbeit für alle ist
hoffen sie oft red abgebildet also die
vorstellung naja das befreit ja auch
wenn die maschinerie übernimmt dann
vielleicht noch ausgestattet mit einem
grundeinkommen daran haben
endlich zeit und was sagt noch zwischen
zu gehen und so denken wagen
mittagstischen das fischen mittags wagen
abends kritisieren ja das ist ja ich
meine das ist ein tolles bild finde ich
das ist auch ein sehr interessanter
punkt wenn man sich fragt welche rolle
die arbeit eigentlich für die marke
thierry spielt oder auch für die für
leben sozusagen für die max tätig wenn
man so will oder seine vorstellung davon
was ein vom kapitalismus befreites gutes
freies richtiges leben wäre weil es ja
wirklich beide dimensionen gibt es gibt
das berühmte zitat wer sagt naja oder
und die berühmte vorstellung dass am
ende ja wenn wir alles nutzen was uns
zur verfügung steht und wenn die
maschinerie und wenn die entwicklung der
produktivkräfte im sinne der menschen
und das füreinander und für die
bedürfnisse der anderen produzieren
eingesetzt werden wenn man dann aber
auch alle technologischen mittel besser
maßen nutzen würde und zum wohle der
menschen nutzen würde statt sie damit
immer schlimmere zwangsherrschaft zu
bringen das war ja im grunde dass das
skandalon das herausgearbeitet hat wenn
das alles also alles gelungen wäre dann
werden wir auch frei von der arbeit im
sinne von dann müssten wir nicht mehr so
einen großen teil unserer zeit dafür
einsetzen und könnten weiß nicht ob max
und surfen gegen gedacht hat aber
könnten eben unsere lebenszeit anders
und mit vielen anderen eher verbringen
das ist das ein element das andere
element ist ja das mag gedacht hat dass
arbeit ein wesentlicher bestandteil
nicht nur der menschwerdung des menschen
des menschseins ist dessen wie menschen
sich auf sich und auf ihre welt beziehen
und dadurch zu etwas machen also kurz
gefasst arbeit als selbstverwirklichung
arbeit als das was sozusagen der
spezifisch menschliche beitrag und auch
worin in bestimmten hinsicht eben auch
das gute und freie leben besteht
und ich glaube da gibt es eine spannung
die gar nicht richtig aufgelöst ist
einerseits freiheit von der arbeit
andererseits arbeit als teil und element
unserer frei halbjahr was sie
wahrscheinlich bei so einem knackpunkt
weil sich dann auch die frage gestellt
welche arbeit kann so sprechen wir mal
mit axel honneth kann so ein comeback
der anerkennung sein was ja auch ein
ganz wichtiger begriff ist in der ganzen
kritischen theorie also das wäre ja
wahrscheinlich nicht die fließbandarbeit
das kommt ja darauf an also will doch
noch auf die frage der dicke also auf
die frage ist jetzt digitalisierung
seien oder nicht man kann doch sagen die
digitalisierung sofern sie uns monotone
langweilige sinnlose nervtötende arbeit
abnimmt es durchaus ein element von
freiheit digitalisierung sofern sie
bestimmte dinge wiederum unmöglich macht
also nicht nur menschen ausschließt aus
der arbeit sondern auch sozusagen selber
eine art von arbeit kreiert die eben ein
ganz spezifischer weise nervtötend ist
hat dann wiederum eine ganz andere
also man muss das glaube ich jeweils im
kontext dessen was damit möglich gemacht
wird wieder mit was welche tätigkeiten
damit verbunden sind aber auch welche in
welchen einfluss menschen darauf haben
was hier mit ihrem leben geschieht da
sind wir wahrscheinlich auch bei denen
was sie interessiert an der
kapitalismuskritik ich habe das so
verstanden wenn ich ihm an ihren beitrag
liest in diesem band nach marxen wandten
sie herausgegeben haben nach ihrer
großen marx konferenz 2011 die sie
veranstaltet haben
da haben sie es gibt eine streife der
kapitalismuskritik es gibt einerseits
wirklich die divi nennen sie das die
kritik die funktional ist da sagt man
wirklich kapitalismus wird sich selber
abschaffen der überlegt sich nicht mehr
funktioniert einfach nicht wann gibt es
die moralische kapitalismuskritik die
sagt dass es immer verbunden mit
ausbeutungsverhältnisse und führt eben
zu ungleichen verhältnissen und es gibt
das was sie die ethische
kapitalismuskritik nennen und dann geht
es ihnen darum dass sie sagen
kapitalismus ist keine lebensform die
für uns taugt was meinen sie damit
genauer
also zum einen ist also meine position
hier ist und das führt auch nochmal auf
mag so ich glaube was was an der maxime
kapitalismuskritik interessant ist ist
das hier eigentlich alle diese drei
momente der kapitalismus kritik enthält
wie man eben überhaupt marx glaube ich
so unter dem gesichtspunkt betrachten
muss dass er kapitalismuskritik nicht
erfunden hat sondern eher eine ganz
bestimmte wendung gegeben hat eine der
wichtigen momente ist glaube ich dass es
eben keine rein moralisierende
kapitalismuskritik ist sondern dass es
ein versuch ist die spezifische dynamik
des kapitalismus zu verstehen und aus
dieser dynamik selber auch gewissermaßen
die die normativen maßstäbe der kritik
zu gewinnen und das ist eine
interessante mischung und da gehen dann
diese drei momente die sie genannt haben
also die funktionale kritik die
eigentlich die krisen kritik die wir
gerade gehört haben ist auch wenn es da
viel passierte hre modelle weil man
selber natürlich gibt die moralische
kritik die sagen würde es ist ungerecht
dass es eine ungleiche verteilung von
ressourcen es führt zur ausbeutung und
die ethische kritik die gehen da glaube
ich eine mischung miteinander ein
also max hat alle drei dimensionen vor
augen und in der hinsicht glaube ich
dass wenn man sich klarmacht dass
produktionsweisen eben auch lebensweisen
oder lebensformen sind die nicht nur
darauf beruhen dass das sie lebensform
die es vorher gab also vor
kapitalistisch gab sich angeeignet haben
zum teil sehr gewalttätig angeeignet
haben und umgeformt haben also der
kapitalismus braucht ja auch einen
bestimmten typ von menschen die
beispielsweise sich der industriellen
arbeitsdisziplin wenn es überhaupt
unterziehen dafür geeignet sind mit der
art von zeit regime umzugehen erzählt er
auch da wird im kapital ja viel also
viele diese dieser dinge werden
beschrieben was ist eigentlich braucht
um überhaupt bisher maßen die menschen
und die gesellschaft kapitalismus fähig
zu machen welche art von enteignung auch
von dem was vorher gemeineigentum war
dem vorher gtc
also ich glaube dass kapitalismus eine
lebensform ist weil sie diese diese
transformiert auf diese angewiesen ist
ist ein ganz ganz entscheidender punkt
eine perspektive ist jetzt sozusagen wir
sollten alle diese drei dimensionen von
kritik zusammennehmen gewissermaßen wir
sollten sehen dass die moralische kritik
nicht frei stehend sein kann sondern
dass sie eingebettet ist in die beiden
anderen dimensionen
das führt dann am ende dazu zu sagen
wenn kapitalismus ein übel ist dann ist
er es als eine lebensform oder oder
unter dieser breiten perspektive dessen
dass hier nicht nur einfach zu sagen
ökonomische prozesse viel laufen das
funktional werden können sondern dass
das was mit unserer lebenswelt mit
unseren lebensformen in unseren
alltäglichen praktiken und vorzügen hier
beeinflusst wird und schief gehen kann
dass das ein problem ist ja vielleicht
müssen wir den begriff auch noch besser
verstehen sie haben dieses buch
geschrieben kritik von lebensformen
dieser begriff der lebensform ist ihnen
ganz wichtig und daran haben sie viel
gearbeitet und wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden haben geht es darum dass sie
sagen eine lebensform ist nicht einfach
ein subjektives lebensgefühl etwas was
ich jetzt so für mich gestaltet es ist
aber auch nicht einfach ein objektiv
werte basierte beschreibung des guten
lebens das wir sagen genauso müssen
menschen leben ansonsten scheitert das
gute leben sondern es ist etwas
dazwischen es geht um soziale praktiken
also um dinge die wir gemeinsam aus
gemeinschaft aus lebensform eben
irgendwie uns gegeben haben
gleichzeitig sagen sie und da kommt
glaube ich dann normative begriffen auch
mit rein
es müssen irgendwie formen seien das
zusammengehen sind in die etwas lernen
können
kann sie das noch ein bisschen
deutlicher machen können sie mal eine
lebensform nennen wo sie sagen würden
dass ich jetzt wirklich kritikwürdig
so sollten wir nicht liegen naja man
kann also das ist eben tatsächlich die
frage wie weist man eigentlich welche
art von also wir können kapitalismus
beschreiben wir können sagen
der funktioniert auf diese und jene art
und weise und man kann sagen da gehen
viele sachen schief da gibt es nur eine
art und weise in der die bedingungen der
eigenen existenz untergraben werden es
gibt massive ungerechtigkeiten es gibt
ausbeutung es gibt das was auch schon
mal in fremden einander es gibt
sozusagen ein
das gefühl der machtlosigkeit und der
sinnlosigkeit die mit bestimmten
praktiken denen wir ausgesetzt sind oder
in der deren teil wir sind einhergeht
man kann sich von und warum ist das denn
falsch und die in welcher hinsicht ist
beispielsweise die erfahrung der disti
wie tät kapitalistischen wirtschaftens
eigentlich eine die in die weitere die
hier überhaupt gemacht werden kann oder
die aus der konsequenzen gezogen werden
können dann kann man sich fragen warum
können die konsequenz nicht gezogen
werden weil es blockaden gibt nicht nur
dafür überhaupt zu verstehen und zu
sehen was hier eigentlich vorgeht
sondern natürlich auch systematisch zu
sagen durch soziale herrschaft bedingte
unmöglichkeiten hier das was im
interesse einer großen mehrheit der
bevölkerung liegen sollte in diesem sinn
umzusetzen
ich glaube ich verstehe was sie
beschreiben ich denke für viele klingt
das doch relativ technisch wenn wir
vielleicht einfach mal ein beispiel
nehmen wir nehmen wir das beispiel von
menschen die so couch potato musikleben
die gehen am morgen in die zu einer
arbeit die sie aus sinnentleert
empfinden
am abend kommt sie nach hause und hängen
sich mit dem bier vor dem fernseher und
gucken da beijing mäßig irgendwelche
serien und und essen hamburger viele
würden wahrscheinlich sagen na ja es ist
deren freier wille die können so
entscheiden wenn sie jetzt haben sie
gibt genau 1 1 ausnahme von instrumenten
forum zu sagen na ja freiheit in ehren
aber es geht eben nicht nur um die
freiheit jetzt zu entscheiden will ich
abends hamburger essen und fernsehen
gucken sondern es geht überhaupt darum
den menschen möglichkeiten zu geben was
sie aus ihrem leben auch noch machen
könnte mich dass die stoßrichtung also
das ist sicher ein wichtiger und
interessanter punkt ich glaube ich will
nicht dass ich wenig individuen ihre
individuellen entscheidungen
ihre individuellen lebens option endlich
weise davon sollen so mit einer
paternalistischen ich weiß was ich
besser ist und warum euer leben verkehrt
ist kritisieren man versucht ist
eigentlich also auch hier zu sagen es
geht hier um die es geht um die
strukturen die bestimmte möglichkeiten
also die die sozusagen reichhaltige
entscheidungsmöglichkeiten vorgeben oder
nicht und möglicherweise ist die
entscheidung zwischen also es gibt
entscheidungen von dem man sagen kann
klar die hat man in einer gesellschaft
die viele konsolen angebot gemacht hat
man den übergroßen maße man könnte sich
jetzt fragen sind das tatsächlich die
entscheidung und die alternativen vor
denen man gestellt sein sollte um zu
sagen das was man was man in einem sehr
tiefen sinne als autonome entscheidungen
wo man sich wirklich zwischen
unterschiedlichen lebensweisen
entscheiden können überhaupt treffen
kann und sie haben recht ich schrecke
davor zurück das ich will nicht in diese
alte haltung die man ja also der der
älteren teil kritischen theorie häufig
vorgerechnet zu dieser alte
paternalistische die massen sind stumpf
und von der kulturindustrie verblödet
haltung in das möchte ich nicht gerne
nicht gerne zurück ich möchte aber
trotzdem die frage stellen können ja vor
welchem hintergrund menschen eigentlich
bestimmte entscheidungen für bestimmte
lebensfunktionen treffen und ich möchte
trotzdem eine gesellschaftliche debatte
darüber da eine politisch demokratische
debatte darüber welche
lebensmöglichkeiten welche lebensformen
welche praktiken eigentlich sinnvoll gut
und jetzt in einem umfassenderen sind
auch frei sind weil es ja tatsächlich so
ist also wenn man dass couch potato
beispiel nimmt dann denkt man also dann
liegt so auf der einen seite so offen zu
tage das schade doch niemanden dass die
leute doch machen
[Musik]
das ist etwas wo man so sehr schnell mit
dem liberalen argument also solange man
niemanden niemandem schadet soll man
machen kann aber jeder auf seine person
geht ja in einer modernen gesellschaft
gar nicht so leicht
es gibt ja immer die frage wie man
bestimmte ressourcen verteilen möchte
man gerne dass es so etwas wie gut
ausgestattete öffentliche schulen gibt
in denen es auch einen geist gesehen ist
doch aber auch wahnsinnig interessant
also ein begriff den sie auch sehr stark
machen und im moment auch in diesem
zentrum über das wir gesprochen haben
leitbegriff ist der begriff der
emanzipation und dieses freiheits
bemühen aus marx heraus aus der
kritischen theorie heraus fruchtbar zu
machen für die heute gesellschaftskritik
und genau wie sie sagen welche
bildungsangebote stellen wir bereit also
wenn ihr einen emanzipation gedanken
haben müssen wir als immer fragen
woraufhin den emanzipieren
also haben die nicht doch immer so ein
sage ich jetzt auch mal objektiv ist
ideal woraufhin die gesellschaft sich
hin entwickeln soll
das ist eben genau genau das problem
also die die die intention hinter man
überlegungen hier ist jetzt ja
tatsächlich zu sagen die vorstellung
dass man das alles so für sich alleine
entscheiden könnte solange es niemand
anderen an dem schaden und dass es keine
voraussetzungen hat die schon über die
schon öffentlich und gesellschaftlich
entschieden ist das ist eben eine
illusion also in gewisser weise bedient
man damit dann die vorstellung dass die
institutionen die wir jetzt haben also
ökonomische institution politische
institutionen gesellschaftliche
institutionen aller art als ob die
gewissermaßen der naturgegebene
hintergrund für das was wir da noch auf
der ebene individuelle freiheit
entscheiden können müssen aber es ist ja
so dass diese dinge alles schon geprägt
und geformt sind also dass auch die art
und weise wie wir uns entscheiden die
die option die wir haben geformt sind
durch ein durch ressourcen über die wir
gar nicht anders können als öffentlich
gemeinsam zu entscheiden also sehr viel
von dem was wir es also in bestimmten
gesellschaft da ist ja
selbstverständlich bestands
voraussetzungen auffassen darüber wird
ja muss ja politisch geredet werden
darum als wir können gewissermaßen diese
ethischen fragen da nicht außen vor
lassen wir können gar nicht sagen wir
sind demgegenüber hat
und da ist ja auch ein sehr
interessanter punkt das habe ich gelesen
in einem gespräch das sie geführt haben
mit taten und rosa zusammen der ja auch
diesen begriff der entfremdung immer
wieder aufgreift der beschleunigung die
uns alle so quält dass sie sagen na ja
alle rennen in therapien alle meditieren
oder optimieren sich um irgend in diesem
system klar zu kommen und die leute
machen sich nicht klar dass sie
eigentlich ja auch ein sage ich jetzt
mal doch ein opfer des systems sind und
dass ihr eigentlich
gesellschaftskritisch überlegen müssten
also eigentlich ist es ein drama
sondergleichen dass wir die probleme die
wir erleben als moderne individuen die
kranken system die haben die in unsere
seele hinein gepackt und lassen sie uns
jetzt weg therapieren
was sollten wir denn staub dessen tun
also ich glaube das ist eine ganz
wichtige diagnose die auch tatsächlich
ein anderer habe das sind auch immer
mehr zu er diese diese vorstellung oder
im grunde diese verschiebung dass die
menschen weil sie sonst an ihrem leben
nicht viel ändern können oder weil sie
es sich sonst in bestimmten hinsichten
als völlig ohnmächtig ihrem schicksal
und den den gesellschaftlichen
verhältnissen ausgeliefert empfinden
optimieren sie an sich selber rum oder
glauben sie dass sie durch alle
möglichen arten von eben selbst
optimierungs techniken und finden
therapie techniken und von körper
techniken etc bis hin zu dieser immensen
diesem immensen fokus auf fragen der
ernährung was wo ja auch so eine
manipulation sbd geradezu schon herrscht
ja dass man glaubt ihr nicht mehr dieser
substanz immer regelmäßig zu führen
werde ich so hoch wie nie und wenn ich
jenes mache dann werde ich also da merkt
man ja manchmal wenn man sich diese also
die diese erläuterungen exkurse dazu
anhält merkt man ja da ist das so ein
irrer und ich würde sagen fehlgeleiteter
kontrollen waren dem zugrunde liegt ja
ich möchte wenigstens kontrollieren dass
ich zu mir nehme ich möchte wenigstens
kontrollieren wie jeder meine muskeln
und also wie auch immer dann den
verschiedenen esoterische vorstellung
über körper funktion vorzunehmen wie das
alles funktioniert da möchte ich
einfluss nehmen können und da glaube ich
schon dass es nicht verkehrt dass zu
sagen das ist etwas was eine reaktion
also dazu muss man nicht sehr parteiisch
sein um sich mindestens die frage
stellen zu können ist das nicht eine
reaktion darauf dass das was man dass
dies werden die das eigene leben
wirklich betreffen und die das eigene
leben zum teil sehr leidvoll werden
lassen dass das genau dinge sind an
denen die menschen glauben oder von dem
sie auch die erfahrung machen dass sie
dabei wenig mitsprache haben wenig daran
ändern können und das verlagert sich
daneben auf seine komischen weise in die
vorstellung irgendwie ist man ja dann
doch auch selber schuld und man kann
genau das mit sich selber ausmachen die
alternative also als philosophin kann es
natürlich jetzt sagen naja
gesellschaftskritik das macht kritische
theorie und deswegen sind sie an diesem
zentrum deswegen ist das ihr
forschungsinteresse also dass ich meine
das hört sich super an
ich finde großartig was ist mit den
leuten da draußen nein aber ich meine es
ist tatsächlich die alternative ist ganz
dumm und ganz platt gesagt demokratie
demokratie wie aufgefasst in einem sehr
breiten sinne demokratie als auch
wiederum demokratie als lebensform die
alltägliche sozusagen in die
alltäglichen institutionen einsickert
und da also die sozusagen unser ganzes
leben in vielen der verschiedenen
kontexten in denen wir mit anderen zu
tun haben und am sozialen leben
teilhaben betreffen würde das wird sich
jetzt so an wie ein gedanke ich meine
das gibt es auch schon sehr lange stimmt
ja auch gibt es aber nicht der umstand
aber dass die menschen sich gerade nicht
und gerade zu den demokratischen
institutionen nicht unbedingt das
verhältnis haben dass sie sich dadurch
vertreten fühlen oder glauben autor der
kollektiven verhältnisse zu sein die
eigentlich demokratische institution
schaffen sollen das ist so also so wenig
überraschend diese diagnose ist aber so
sehr ist das doch tatsächlich er dann
kann ja auch sagen kommt ja nicht von
ungefähr dass dieses geld ihnen gegeben
wurde um eben die krise des kapitalismus
und der demokratie zu erforschen oder da
sieht man ja auch schon wie die dinge
wahrscheinlich zusammenhängen
genau also ich meine die frage wie
beides miteinander kompatibel ist ist ja
doch eine also zum einen glaube ich eben
man sollte sowohl den kapitalismus in
einem sehr breiten sinne den wir im
grunde
ja auch schon sehr lange in einem
bestimmten typ von westlich marx is muss
von durch die kritische theorie
beeinflussten aber auch durch ganz viele
andere richtung beeinflussen
marxistischen überlegungen da ist die
perspektive dass es hier um ein sehr
vielfältiges ein komplexer eine komplexe
gesellschaft und wirtschaftsweise geht
die man eben nicht im engen sinne
ökonomisch viele interpretieren sollte
der das ist ja sehr weit verbreitet auch
umgekehrte demokratie sollte man nicht
nur als eine regierungsform deren
legitimität man untersuchen kann auf
fassen sondern eben in jenem breiten
sinne indem und hier kommt das stichwort
emanzipation in dem demokratie bedeutet
dass menschen sich in dem sinne
emanzipieren dass hier tatsächlich mit
autoren ihre lebensumstände werden und
dass wir beides untersuchen in diesem
zentrum hat auch etwas damit zu tun dass
ich glaube heute die frage wie vereinbar
eigentlich demokratie und kapitalismus
sind sich wirklich also sehr scharf
stellt immer wieder neu stellt das war
von beginn an ja entspannungs verhältnis
das auch wiederum unter anderem arques
sehr viel dazu beigetragen hat deutlich
zu machen dass es hier grenzen geben
könnte es gab dann eine lange phase wo
man geglaubt hat
das wurde im film ja auch angesprochen
es gab dann gewerkschaften dass gegen
bestimmte andere auch der gesamten
demokratischen zähmung des kapitalismus
die sehr lange gelungen sheen in einer
bestimmten konstellation und ich glaube
heute ist die situation die dass sich
sehr viele fragen gelingt eigentlich
eine solche zählung ist das überhaupt
möglich genau und wie funktioniert
sozusagen die einmischung und sie selber
ich weiß nicht ob sie das mögen wenn ich
das erzählen aber ich finde das so
interessant sie sind ja selber mit 410
von zu hause ausgezogen waren in der
hausbesetzerszene
und wenn man ihren werdegang sozusagen
anguckt heute sind sie eine der
renommiertesten pastorin für philosophie
an der hu
da frage ich mich auch ist für sie heute
sozusagen der zivile ungehorsam dieses
wirklich aufstehen und auf die straße
gehen und kämpfen
ist das für sie auch sozusagen ein
legitimes mittel
werden sie da gehen also ja sicher ich
glaube auch dass demokratie gar nicht
anders funktionieren kann und dass man
dieses moment also dass das hier soziale
bewegungen auftreten die für bestimmte
für bestimmte dinge einstehen
zusammenhänge herstellen
nicht nur ihre interessen sondern auch
sozusagen die art und weise wie sie
leben wollen politisch zum ausdruck
bringen und sich in ihrer lage zu sagen
verstehen und dann auch kollektiv
verstehen und hier etwas tun ich glaube
dass das das ein moment der demokratie
ist was überhaupt nicht wegzudenken ist
und wir sehen dass wir immer wieder dass
es ohne dass es diese art von
thematisierung gibt auch viele
politische fragen eben gar nicht
überhaupt auf die agenda gesetzt würden
man kann jetzt sagen das lässt nach oder
das wird hat heute auch wiederum ganz
anderes hätten digitalisierung
angesprochen das hat ja auch medial
heute ganz andere bedingungen aber dass
das immer noch eine der also ich glaube
im grunde dass das an solchen
kollektiven mobilisierungen gar nicht
viel vorbeiführt oder das dass das eine
der unter anderem deshalb weil es ja
auch das was weil es weil es die
subjekte überhaupt erst zu auch wieder
das thema emanzipation überhaupt als zu
individuen macht die sich in der art und
weise mit ihrer umwelt auseinandersetzen
die sich mit den anderen
auseinandersetzen die solidarität
entwickeln
dieses vorher nicht unbedingt gibt die
über die anfangen dinge zu thematisieren
an der welt in der sie leben die ihnen
vorher ist ganz ungreifbar oder auch
unveränderbar erschienen sind
also ich glaube sozusagen dieses
dynamische moment ist schon oder oder
sagen wir so die heiße phase der der
sogar auseinandersetzung ist immer noch
sehr wichtig ich glaube nur dass man auf
der anderen seite kann man natürlich
nicht alles daraufsetzen ich will
unbedingt mit ihnen noch gerne darüber
sprechen wie man denn sozusagen die welt
verändert weil es ja darum irgendwie zu
gehen scheint und da hat ja marx
durchaus ein ambivalentes verhältnis
dazu ich finde das immer wieder
erstaunlich sich klar zu machen etwas
ich glaube viele leute auch sich
umgekehrt vorstellen das mag es
eigentlich überhaupt kein utopist war
marx glaubte nicht daran dass man mit
einer idee die welt verändern kann und
das ist etwas was sie im neuen buch
beschäftigt was im nächsten herbst
erscheinen wird fortschritt und
regression
und die sagen ganz klar wir müssen uns
klar machen es geht nicht darum dass sie
ideen entwickeln können und dann sagen
wir mal so wären ungefähr die ideale
theorie einer gesellschaft und dann
marschrichtung da geht's jetzt lang
sondern es geht immer darum dass die
verhältnisse die gesellschaft die sie
gerade sind tickt die ideen irgendwie
spiegelt und das ist so eine
rückkoppelung die genau verändern wir
dann etwas wenn wir darauf angewiesen
sind dass die gesellschaft da auch mal
was rolle
naja ich also ich glaube wirklich dass
das ein wichtiger punkt ist immer noch
gar nicht oft genug betonen kann das mag
es eben kein utopist während dass das
genau der einsatz ist gegen ganz viele
andere auch also auch zeitgenössische
bewegungen und damalige bewegungen das
genau ist daran aktuell ja das ist nicht
einfach irgendwie ein klasse eine am
grünen tisch entworfene utopie oder eine
bloße ein bloßes normatives idealist und
das in zwei hinsichten glaube ich man
das eines das dass er wirklich daran
interessiert war zu sehen welche
bedingungen sich in der in der
veränderung der gesellschaftlichen
wirklichkeit selber welche also wie sich
sozusagen möglichkeiten
herauskristallisieren wie ist das was in
einem seiner berühmten stelle sagt er
revolution bedürfen eines passiven und
eines aktiven elements und das passive
element sind sozusagen sind
das kann man jetzt also ich würde sagen
man muss das sehr komplex verstehen und
vielleicht auch komplexer verstehen es
mag es dass manchmal gemacht hat aber
das passive im moment sind die ist
natürlich das gesamt all der bedingung
der ökonomischen bedingungen die sich
verändern der der neuen technologien die
die sich entwickeln plus verschiedene
transformationen in lebensweisen von
lebensweisen die nicht unbedingt dadurch
vorgebracht werden dass menschen sich
überlegen dass sie irgendetwas jetzt
nicht mehr richtig und gut finde und das
deshalb bewusst ändern sondern die sich
in auseinandersetzungen auch mit
materiellen bedingungen entwickeln und
es gibt es aktive momente und das aktive
moment sind sind ja einerseits eben dann
tatsächlich die soziale akteure die so
etwas umsetzen darüber haben wir schon
geredet
ich finde das interessante an der andere
in den märkischen überlegungen hier der
ja auch zum kapitalismus das
zwiespältige verhältnis hatte dass er
die unglaubliche dynamische kraft
gesehen hat also der kapitalismus ist
die entwicklung das finden wir im
kommunistischen manifest ja so
ausdrucksstark ja die alles bestehende
pulverisiert ja die alles alles
ständische verdampfen lässt sie sind
sozusagen die bedingungen dafür
bereitstellt es die ganze welt sich
verändern kann und die hoffnung ist
jetzt dass sich auch die sozialen
herrschaftsverhältnisse dadurch
verändern und das also einerseits
bedient sich gegenseitig sie bringen ein
beispiel ich würde das gerne besser noch
verstehen die sagen wir haben zb so
etwas heute wie den strafbestand der
straftatbestand der vergewaltigung in
der ehe
lange zeit war die gesellschaft so
gestrickt dass männer sich einfach holen
konnten in der ehe was sie hat wollten
es gab da keine straftat sozusagen
heute ist das anders wie sind die dahin
gekommen nicht in dem sich leute zuerst
mal ausgedacht haben das können wir doch
jetzt bestrafen sondern nimmt sich die
gesellschaft zuerst verwandelt hatten
sie verweisen dann auf eine stelle aus
dem kapital dritter bauen wo sie sagen
das so es ist also bei marx der sagt
beim privateigentum ist es so irgendwann
werden die eine gesellschaftsformation
haben basiert das privateigentum an
einzelnen teilen des erdballs so
abgeschmackt erscheinen wie das
privateigentum von menschen anderen
menschen also was macht eigentlich sagt
ist das wird uns irgendwann einfach
geschmacklos erscheinen
es geht nicht darum dass es unmoralisch
ist es sich irgendwie geschmacklos ist
das wirklich alles was wir dazu sagen
soll
nein natürlich ist es unmoralisch und
ich glaube auch nicht dass meist nicht
geglaubt hat dass es abscheulich
unmoralisch und widerwärtig ist menschen
zu besitzen ja sein dass im vorteilen
info dein verhältnissen oder in anderen
form der sklaverei
aber das interessante daran ist also ich
finde auch tatsächlich dieses wort
abgeschmackte und so interessant weil
das klingt erstmal so ästhetisch ja so
abgeschmackt irgendwie genau ethik als
geschmackssache
und das ist natürlich das ist nicht
gemeint also ich glaube das interessante
dabei ist dass er damit eigentlich eine
antwort darauf versucht auf die frage
die uns ja manchmal beschäftigt wenn wir
uns mit solchen mit moralischen
fortschritt befassen ja manchmal
versteht man ja überhaupt nicht wie in
einer früheren zeit in einer anderen
sozialen konstellation dinge für ganz
normal gehalten werden konnten wirklich
viel völlig selbstverständlich die
nachdem sich der fortschritt ereignet
hat oder oder also sich die moralischen
sensibilitäten geändert haben scheint es
ein undenkbar also gewisse formen der
tierhaut ezb denkt man heute einfach
geht nicht niedergang man ja natürlich
jede form von sklaverei also nicht dass
es sie heute nicht noch gebe es gibt sie
gibt sie unter anderem namen in anderen
rechtlichen bedingungen
leider wie wir wissen in vielen formen
aber sozusagen eine öffentlich
anerkannte institutionelle form des
tatsächlich eigentums an menschen mit
einem verfügungsrecht gehört ja auch in
diesem sommer aber um eben dieses kleine
beispiel an dem man aufzeigen kann da
hat sich ja eben was verändert der
vergewaltigung in der ehe zu nehmen
schon da finde ich kann man gut sehen
das was hier passiert ist dass ich und
ich glaube darauf wer mag es mit diesem
abgeschmackt hinaus dass sich die
rahmenbedingungen ändern dass ich die
der gesamten kontext ändert also
abgeschmackt sagt man deshalb hier weil
es nicht einfach so ist dass man jetzt
eine andere position dazu hatte eine
andere idee dazu entwickelt hat sondern
es erscheint einem undenkbar und die
frage ist wie kommt es eigentlich zu
dieser art der und dankbarkeit und
darauf ist die antwort weiß ich sehr
viele sagen wir um grenzende bedingungen
geändert haben das sind wenn wir den
fall der vergewaltigung in der ehe jetzt
nehmen dass das für bestimmte
in bestimmten zeiten so zu sagen wo
moralisch unproblematisch erscheinen
konnte ich glaube nicht dass es den
opfern jemals und moralischen probleme
hat irgendwo ein politisch entschieden
ist aber sagen wir das ist
gesellschaftlich so unter mindestens
ferner liefen qualifiziert wurde das hat
das damit zu tun dass die männer damals
auch oder was damals ist solange auch
über die arbeitsverträge der
frontscheibe das entscheiden durften ob
die frauen überhaupt berufstätig sein
durften und beispielsweise ohne ohne
zustimmung der frau arbeitsvertrag
auflösen durften das hat auch was damit
zu tun dass alle möglichen arten der
ökonomischen abhängigkeit oder dessen
das überhaupt eben wenn man in der ehe
alle lebensentscheidung für die frau
treffen dürfte es hat auf der anderen
seite um eine ganz andere dynamik
anzusprechen auch etwas damit zu tun wie
wie die vorstellung von liebe wie die
vorstellung von sexualität welche ideen
und interpretationen ist dazu gibt also
sozusagen die eine sehr passive
interpretation dessen was was was frauen
hier eigentlich wollen welche art von
von von leidenschaft im spiel ist all
das zusammen und das finde ich
eigentlich dass das was man sozusagen
aus dieser idee dass moralischer
fortschritt sich im kontext von sehr
vielen anderen institutionen und
praktiker praktiker ereignet all das
zusammen ja eine bestimmte vorstellung
davon was die sexualität an der frau
überhaupt ausmacht eine bestimmte
selbstverständlichkeit mit der der mann
ökonomisch der haushaltsvorstand war
alle möglichen anderen rechtlichen
bestimmungen das alles zusammen führt in
dem fall zu einer konstellation wo einem
dann sozusagen dieses i-tüpfelchen der
das recht auf sexuelle übergriffe gar
nicht merkt also oder wo man versteht
warum das gar nicht warum das in dem
kontext irgendwie ganz
selbstverständlich erscheinen kommt wir
sind mitten in der gesellschaftskritik
aber am ende unseres gesprächs das heißt
wir müssen noch lange weiter überlegen
was alles denn abgeschmackt ist und
vielleicht ein stück weit darauf hoffen
dass wir noch neue formen finden die wir
die abgeschmackten dinge analysieren
können
und hoffe ich doch beseitigen können ich
danke ihnen sehr frau jäckel dass sie zu
uns getränke im land gesehen
nächste woche reisen je nach israel
ich boxe trifft den bedeutenden
schriftsteller amos oz und spricht mit
ihm über den konflikt zwischen israeli
und palästinensern und über die wurzeln
des fanatismus am 23 mai laden wieder
zum philosophischen stammtisch nach
basel liefern den philosophischen
nachklapp zu mieten und fragen was es
neues gibt puncto feminismus
ich freue mich wenn sie live dabei sind
tickets gibt es auf unserer website und
jetzt gleich sagen wir der schönheit
nach chasing beauty heißt das
filmporträt über den zürcher fotografen
walter pfeiffer der die modefotografie
zur kunst erhoben vergnügen und eine
gute woche für sie
[Musik]